okay fantastic so what i'm gonna do is
see if we can remember how to use some
of this stuff
i promised you can open your laptops
back up now or open them up for the
first time if you didn't before
we're in exercise 5a so you can pull
that up
and rather than do like a whole bunch of
explanation and then just set you for
the rest of the double to do
these exercises that seems a bit boring
to me so instead what we're going to do
is
we're going to sort of chip away at this
and i want you to i want to help you
remember all the bits that you've done
like this is a reintroduction you've
seen this before a lot of this
exercise 5a you can see let's just start
with question one can i ask you guys to
do this you can do this independently
check it
at your table groups question one
is about this same idea right you don't
need to draw the diagram um but i will
insist for question one
that you do actually write the question
you can see there it says say for
example part a
cos alpha so you may well work out what
ratio it is but don't just give me a
fraction don't just give me a number
don't just say like one-seventh i want
you to write down
cos alpha equals one-seventh i mean it's
not one-seventh because i just made up
those numbers
but that actual question tells me what
the answer is
okay just to make sure we're on this on
the right track looking at that diagram
there
on exercise 5a can someone tell me what
cos alpha is in this particular triangle
have a look do you see it there which
ratio are we looking at cos alpha it's
the
adjacent on hypotenuse so which is the
adjacent side how long is it
have a look on the the diagrams there
right on the right hand side
are you still letting up okay that's
fine i'm too impatient sorry
uh well you know what while that's
loading i'll just draw it up for you
very good so what do we got here just
for the people who are still loading it
up
um there's the three or just let's
actually i'm now wondering because i'm
just putting the sizing yeah okay
fantastic so we fixed it up that's right
so we're looking at cos alpha so just
like
sorry my beat is very very messy let's
fix that just like before
we're looking at a particular angle in
this case it's called theta
we like using greek letters for our
angles because we run out of letters
basically and we're after adjacent our
hypotenuse so
as we'll said here's 3 which is adjacent
and here's 5 which is
hypotenuse makes sense so our answer for
this part a will be
please write it out like so cos alpha
equals
three over five
that's john purchase isn't i'm shutting
that door so um that's how i'd love you
to set it out don't just put three
fifths
because later on you'll look at all
these and you think what did any of them
mean so go ahead do question one that'll
take you a minute or so
and um check it across with the people
at your table to make sure you're on the
right track
all right fantastic have you already
cross-checked against with people at
your desk you're happy with that
okay so again when you're having a look
the key thing really is
to you're doing your brain is doing two
things at every moment when you look at
something like this right
number one it's thinking about uh you
know which ratio of sides
adjacent opposite hypotenuse but
actually the first thing you should
think about is where you're looking from
right so you've got your alpha or your
beta you just want to make sure ah
opposite which angle is it the alpha or
the beta so i'm pretty happy with that
now as you're moving forward we're going
to go a little deeper into this exercise
i want to remind you
of how we think about how to measure
angles like say you know the question in
this case didn't ask you to do this
but if we wanted to find out what alpha
was equal to
if we wanted to find out what its actual
magnitude size was right
you've got your calculators there i
mentioned if you haven't got it i'll get
out now right
what would we do not that the question
asks this but what would we do if we're
in question three i think
to find out what alpha is equal to which
button will be used
yep fantastic so um that shift as you
can see
above the cause button um there's
i think it should say something like
this cause with a negative one
like that i don't even know what this is
called by the way it's got a couple of
different names
you see that minus one there what would
you call that if you're saying to
someone hey press this button
say it again very good it's um inverse
cos cos inverse
um if you see stuff on the internet well
done uh sometimes you'll see it called
not that you have to write this down
actually i think it may have actually
been added um you will sometimes see
this i believe the syllabus for you guys
actually um
they introduced this a year or two ago
in the us
uh this is their way of saying it right
so there's arc cos and arc
sign and arctan and it means the same
thing
just undo it reverse it if you put that
in go ahead and press it and you press
three fifths three fifths
and then you should hit equals can
someone tell me
and um read for me the full calculated
display should be quite a bit in there
right what do you get
[Music]
53 and then you've got a bunch of
decimals okay fantastic i'm going to
pause on the decimals for a second
because what we want to do is and you
may recall this from use 9 and 10 right
we tend not to actually provide angle
answers in decimal we tend not to right
so there's another button that we need
to use to get this out of um
decimal into degrees minutes seconds
remember that what does the button look
like
yeah very good so you got a degree
symbol and then
there's like a an inverted comma right
and then i think if i'm not mistaken
there might be two more
like that right some other people's
calculators it'll literally say
d and then m and then s4 degrees minutes
seconds right um go ahead and punch that
for me can you just
get that yeah three degrees seven
minutes
can you drop that down for me because i
want to talk about this just very
briefly
so we've got an angle size right and you
can see i think i did mention inside the
question three or question four
um you know as promised let me put it
into my calculator as well
make sure i'm in the right mode i'm not
nice work mr wu
trained professional we've done this
before okay so you had
uh what do we have cos inverse of three
over five
okay so we hit the degrees in seconds
there we go that's just
that's a terrible angle hopefully you
can see that okay now we've got it
written here
so which bits are degrees it's the 53
which fits the minutes it's seven does
anyone know why they called minutes by
the way
minutes there's 60 of them in other
words
they're very i kid you not this is where
it comes from they're very
minut they're very small right does
anyone know why these things are called
seconds because this is a
this is a my new division of a degree
this is the second minute division
in fact the full name in like really
like 100 year old textbooks they call
these minutes and second minutes
and their mathematicians famously lazy
right they're like second minutes that's
two whole words man forget it let's just
call it
seconds right so degrees minutes seconds
um it's a bit sneaky right on the end
there you know how we said are we trying
to avoid
decimals but then decimals sneak in why
is that what do i know
it's super accurate our calculator can
get this more accurately than we can
actually even see
we can't even see seconds honestly um
and also we don't no one really uses
i guess we'd call them thirds if there
was a next thing right
um okay so really good when you have a
look at how to input this i want you to
look at question
i think this is question three now let's
have a flick over
this is what i wanted okay so yes
question three
so you can see here right use your
calculator to find correct to four
decimal places then it provides
something like this
okay so how are we going to input that
that's let's just remember this
10 of 57 degrees 30 seconds can you go
ahead on your calculator i'm going to do
it in a second but i'll give you a head
start
how would you put that into your
calculator
okay so ah very good so 57 degrees and
30 minutes because 30 minutes is half of
a degree
you absolutely could let's actually just
do this right now right you could go
can you oh my angle's terrible let me
see if i can get it so i've
got more light is that vaguely better
where do we go
tan just a little bit what do we say
57.5
right so we could use decimal and i
think that would be okay if we already
equals
we're going to get this right now from
memory and you've got in front of you in
fact i think they said four
decimal places four decimal places so in
this case we're going to go
one point help me out
nine fine five six nine seven okay um
it'd be a really safe thing
to put more when we're writing the
answer um especially in an exam
here's not so important but it's a good
thing let's just do it now to write all
of those decimal places that you can see
there what we call the calculator
display
and then your rounding comes next okay
can anyone tell me
um let's just go ahead and write that
tan of 57 degrees
30 minutes equals what would you say can
you read it out for me one
point keep going just give me all of
them
seven seven yep dot dot okay so here's
our calculator display
right and then we can say on our next
line let's do this all together as well
we want four decimal places so five
and actually yeah five and six
and nine are all fine and here comes the
fourth one which we're going to change
stay the same or go up that's going to
go up
so i'll write to four decimal places
do they always care and say an exam
right do they always care about whether
you round it correctly or not
yeah okay so this is interesting right
so you've given me you said sometimes
you said if the question
asks how can you tell like suppose the
question doesn't specify
under what circumstances would you care
about this yeah if
they have used four decimal places
before oh good so the question sometimes
gives you quiz it's like oh everything
here is in four decimal places i guess
we'll do the same
there's first clue second cue is you
know on a question right
the question is written here and then
off on the side here there's a big fat
number in bold right what does that mean
in an exam
that's the number of marks assigned now
just have a look at this if i literally
if you saw this in exam
here's the question here's the number of
marks right does this feel
like two marks worth of work to you
like you're literally just punching some
buttons in calculator right it's barely
one mark of work okay
so why would there be two
because they're looking for the rounding
now they won't do this all the time
right because
you might round like 20 times in an exam
they're not going to ping you
lose 20 marks because you didn't know
how to round you'll lose it once you'll
lose it on that one question where
they're actually saying
hey hey this is important i want you to
show me how you did it okay
um just one last thing we're doing
trigonometry we're measuring things
right
these decimal places they will end up
mattering when you've got very small
angles like this
right think about it this way if you are
measuring can you do a um do a 90 degree
angle between your hands for me
okay do a 90 degree angle now once you
look at yours and i want you to look at
the person
next to you okay do you reckon you've
got exactly the same angle
that's a bit off okay all right now now
i'm going to ask you
okay how confident are you that your 90
degree angle is not say like 89
how confident are you not confident all
right i have no idea i'm like
ish right you can put your hands down
now right so in other words when you're
going like 90 degrees
right does it is it 89 or is it i mean i
guess we go the other way
we've got 91 does anyone know what this
is called by the way
when you're like um kind of in the
ballpark um
we call this errors in measurement it
happens all the time it happens whenever
you
get something and you're like i think
it's like close to there but there's
always a margin for error right
so i think we all tend to agree one
degree not that much of a difference
right now i want you to think again and
imagine what if there was something far
away in the distance
right and you measured the angle and it
turns out the angle is say
two degrees does one degree matter in
this case
[Music]
you bet it does right like the
difference to say one degree is i'm
halving the angle that's a huge
difference when i go off in the distance
to see you know what distance will it
actually mean right
and you know when you think about things
like say in space right we're talking
about
decimal places on decimal place on
decimal places because the distances are
so enormous does that make sense
so anytime you use this in the future do
you guys know how to store things in
your calculator do you know how to do
that
hands up if you're confident you could
come out the front and tell me how to
store stuff in my calculator
two all right that's not enough so all
of you get your calculator out
um do you still have this in your
display this number yeah sorry i'm in
front of the number there you go
if you haven't just put it in again okay
uh 1.56 etc all right now suppose i want
to save this number
for future use so that i'm not using
some rounded off version i'm using this
exact thing
there's even more decimal places the
calculator is just not showing me here's
where we're going to do it okay
whilst it's still there don't clear it
don't do anything right you're going to
go to press
shift up in the top left-hand corner and
then if you sort of look down to these
little buttons here
you see there's one which says sto on it
so sto stands for
storage right so if i hit that if you've
done it right nothing looks like it's
happened but i can't get it to like
can you see right in the top left hand
corner here your calculator display
should say sto right
and now you can pick a letter um you can
see in like
red or magenta right my calculator has
got a b c d
e f and x y m so any of them are
pronumerals that you can use
right so i'm just going to pick uh x
just here so if you press that
what does your calculator say does it
show you what mine shows you
so your answer has been there's the
arrow it's now stored as x
so if you clear that now you've saved it
how do we get back to it you guys knew
how to do it how do i get back
yeah very good so just next to the shift
button there's alpha so you can go alpha
x you can do anything you like to that
you can go like i don't know what if i
double that right
i get this which for me like it's like
1.5 etc
this is an exact value i have an
approximate at all hugely useful when
we're doing this stuff
okay so let me pause there you can see
in question four we're going to start to
get into this territory
right you've been handed some kind of
ratio now i want you to get the angle
out of it
you can see question four asks us to the
nearest degree
so if this were our answer here 53
degrees
seven minutes 48 seconds 48.37
how would we round this to the nearest
degree
um so once you press your degrees minute
seconds that's fine you would get this
and then
am i going to round this down to stay or
up
this is going to this is going to stay
right how many
minutes did we say sorry how many yeah
minutes did we say we're in a degree
there's 60 minutes right so because this
is less than half we're fine
but do be careful if i had this to say
31
minutes 31 minutes we're normally
thinking about like 0.5 but it's not the
same for degrees milliseconds so this
one would round
up degree and if i rounded this two
minutes it would be 53 degrees and
how many minutes it got to 8 because
look this
is above 30. does that make sense that's
a bit sneaky